OK, close your eyes for just a
moment.
Try and picture Washington, DC,
back in the late 90s, maybe
early 2000s.
Can you sort of feel it?
That humid air, kind of heavy
with, I don't know, ambition?
Maybe the faint smell of spale
cigar smoke from those K St.
Power lunches?
You're walking through those
cool, echoing marble corridors
on Capitol Hill, right?
Fluorescent lights humming
overhead, casting this like
sterile glow on interns rushing
past, clutching their lattes in
these folders just bursting with
policy papers.
Yeah, it's a city of facades,
isn't it?
Every conversation feels like
it's got a hidden layer.
Every smile could be, you know,
a negotiation starting.
Exactly.
And just outside those halls,
the power beat goes on.
You've got the black town Cars
lined up like silent Sentinels,
engines idling.
Drivers may be dozing, ready to
whisk some senator official off
to another fundraiser dripping
with PAC money.
You.
Can almost hear the ice clinking
in glasses at the Palm, or maybe
the Mayflower lobbyists
lingering over their drinks.
Voices low, words very precise.
It's just thick with influence,
aspiration, and, I think
critically, secrets.
This was such a different
Washington, a different world
than we know today.
Totally different.
Because this era it wasn't about
quick swipes on Tinder or, you
know, disappearing snaps,
hookups, connections, the kind
that happened way outside public
view.
They were strictly, rigorously
clandestine.
I mean, imagine the stakes.
Just sheer terrifying stakes.
One slip, 1 careless whisper
overheard somewhere, one name
scribbled on a napkin that gets
into the wrong hands, and your
whole legacy, everything you've
built, could just vanish poof up
in smoke.
Because in that town, as our
sources really hammer home, Vice
isn't just a personal failing.
It's like currency, it's a form
of power.
But morality, that's the weapon,
that's the tool that people use
to control, to leverage
sometimes to just utterly
destroy careers.
It's.
The great Washington paradox,
right?
The city projects this image of
moral rectitude, build on
ideals, public service, but it
thrives on the very things that
condemns.
And right into the heart of this
charged, almost theatrical
environment comes this figure
nobody expected.
Deborah Jean Palfrey later, you
know, the infamous DC Madam.
Yeah.
And she?
Wasn't the stereotype you'd
imagine, our sources say no fur
coat, no obviouslys just
described as a smart, incredibly
stubborn woman.
And her most powerful tool, not
some high tech gadget, is the
battered spiral notebook, simple
analogue, her black book.
Her black book, what a name huh?
It just screams intrigue, hidden
power.
And the sources tell us she kept
it not really out of malice.
Not trying to expose people
initially, but pragmatically to
protect herself.
Right, it started as self
preservation.
But this wasn't just a Ledger in
her hands.
That simple notebook became,
well, a hand grenade.
And the crucial part?
She knew precisely when and how
to pull that pin.
You could almost feel the
tension, the paranoia rippling
through Capitol Hill back then.
Young staffers, you know,
sneaking glances at a name maybe
leaked in the paper, then
nervously looking at their boss.
The idea that any name might be
in that book was enough, the
source says, to turn a marble
statue into a sweating,
stammering mess.
You could just picture it and
for a split second, maybe there
is this desperate hope right
this time.
Maybe this swamp might finally
drain itself.
The scandal could be the one.
Of course it didn't.
And that immediate, almost
cynical reality check our
sources give us, well, it sets
the stage perfectly for this
recurring pattern we're digging
into today, a pattern showing
how resilient the system is, how
it just absorbs these shocks.
Exactly.
So today, we're doing a unique
deep dive into two stories that
are deeply connected, maybe
uncomfortably so, Deborah Jean
Palfrey and later Jeffrey
Epstein, because history might
not repeat exactly, but it sure
does rhyme.
And we're here to explore that
striking, often chilling pattern
in Washington's hitting corners,
that pattern of secrets, power,
and information that just stays
buried.
Our mission today is to pull out
the key insights from the
sources you've provided.
We're focusing on those
surprising parallels, right?
The ways power works behind the
scenes, the ways it endures, and
what these stories really tell
us about secrets, information,
accountability, or maybe the
lack of it in DC.
Yeah, we're looking for those
aha moments, the things that
help you get up to speed quickly
on a topic that, let's be
honest, a lot of people would
rather keep hidden.
So let's unpack this.
Let's really set the scene
first.
OK, so let's really dive back
into that atmosphere.
Late 90s rolling into the early
2000s.
Washington, DC.
Our sources paint this picture
not just of a city, but like an
ecosystem.
You've got the gleaming marble
monuments, but also the hushed,
maybe conspiratorial
conversations happening inside
those walls.
Think Capitol Hill.
The frantic rush of interns
contrasted with these serious
looking officials moving
deliberately through back
hallways, past all those
imposing oil portraits.
It feels steeped in tradition,
gravitas, purpose.
But underneath that veneer, the
reality of how things actually
work was quite different.
Like you said, this was before
easy digital connections.
No Tinder, no Snapchat, no
encrypted apps for secret
meetings.
So connections, especially the
illicit kind, had to be
meticulously, painstakingly
secret.
They absolutely had to be.
The stakes were just
astronomical.
One mistake, a name written
down, a slip of the tongue, an
overheard chat and boom.
Career shattered, reputation
gone, legacy extinguished.
Yeah.
The consequences were immediate,
often just irreversible.
And that's that core dynamic,
isn't it?
The source hammers it.
Vice's currency.
But morality is a weapon.
Let's just sit with that for a
second.
People's indiscretions, their
private lives clashing with
their public image.
That's not just personal
baggage.
It becomes leverage, something
to be traded, used against you.
And in a town built on image,
reputation, perceived morality,
the power to expose someone's
secrets is immense, devastating
control.
That's how power really works in
the shadows.
Absolutely.
Secrets aren't just burdens,
they're assets in this high
stakes game.
And then, into this charged,
almost claustrophobic world
steps Deborah Jean Palfrey, Like
the source says, a woman nobody
expected.
Yeah, not the stereotype.
No.
No fur coat, no sleaze, just
described as smart, stubborn,
competent in a, well, let's say
an unsanctified profession.
And her main tool, the thing
that sent tremors through the
city, was that battered spiral
notebook, the Black Book.
Not high tech, just tangible
analog.
Seemingly harmless.
But inside, she meticulously
recorded names, dates, hotel
suites, cash paid.
It was a detailed, accurate
Ledger of discretion of elicit
encounters.
And the key part?
The why?
The source is explicit.
She kept these records to
protect herself.
Exactly.
It wasn't initially about
blackmail.
It was defense, operational
security and a sensitive
business.
But that act of self
preservation, that meticulous
record keeping, it turned the
notebook into, as the source
says, a hand grenade.
And she didn't just have it, she
understood its power.
She knew exactly when to pull
the pin, when to use it as a
deterrent or later, maybe as
retaliation.
This wasn't just notes, it was a
strategic weapon hanging over
powerful heads.
And the ripple effect on the
hill.
When this book became known, you
described it as palpable, almost
sickening.
Staffers pale, glancing at
leaked names, then worried looks
at their boss.
The idea that any powerful name
could be in that book was enough
to turn a marble statue into a
sweating, stammering mess.
It just shows the paralyzing
terror of exposure in a city
built on appearances.
And for that brief moment, that
flicker of hope, maybe this time
the exposure, the hypocrisy
revealed Wood Forest, a real
reckoning.
This swamp might finally drain
itself.
But then the immediate, sobering
reality check.
Of course it didn't.
And that quick dismissal really
sets up the pattern we're
exploring.
It suggests the system, the
mechanisms of power and secrecy
in DC are so deeply rooted they
can just absorb even the most
explosive revelations.
The swamps infrastructure is
just incredibly resilient.
So let's get into the specifics
of Deborah Jean Palfrey's
operation, Pamela Martin and
Associates.
She actually started it back in
the early 90s, and it was, as
our source puts it so politely,
DC's polite euphemism for call
girls you could trust not to
ruin you.
That last part is key, isn't it?
Trust not to ruin you.
Absolutely.
It wasn't about extortion, it
was about discretion for a very
specific clientele.
It really is, and it's a crucial
difference between Pelphrey's
operation and, well, many
others, especially later ones.
This wasn't, like you said, a
stereotypical St. level thing.
Her clients were high end
politicians, senior government
officials, military officers,
lobbyists, businessmen and the
services.
The providers were equally high
end educated women.
Often students are former models
providing fantasy companionship
in upscale rooms.
This wasn't quick encounters in
cheap motels, the sources
stress.
She didn't run dirty motel
rooms.
She ran discreet townhouse
visits and alcohols to luxury
suites in DC's best hotels.
It points to a sophisticated
market, and she understood what
her clients needed most.
Discretion, reliability and a
certain level of, you know,
class that match their public
image.
And a really crucial distinction
the sources make, almost like
they knew Epstein was coming
later, is that this was strictly
for consenting adults.
The source says it flat out yes.
No minors, no blackmail, just
grown men paying to cheat
quietly.
That detail is so important.
It sets Palfrey apart morally
and legally from the much darker
stuff later.
She was providing an illicit
service, yes, but based on adult
consent, focusing on secrecy,
not coercion or exploiting kids.
It was about quiet infidelity,
not blackmail schemes involving
minors.
And that focus on secrecy
directly led to her meticulous
record keeping.
This wasn't casual notes.
It was meticulous records.
A spiral notebook, phone logs,
client notes, detailed entries,
names, dates, addresses, call
durations, even preferences.
Yeah, and not just for business,
like any company might have.
It was her shield herself.
Preservation.
So when the IRS and the feds
finally showed up in 2006, they
weren't just seeing a standard
vice case.
The sheer detail, the
organization, the names, dates,
locations, payments, it wasn't
just evidence of a crime.
They immediately saw it as a
blueprint for blackmail.
Think about that phrase, A
That's terrifying.
The authorities instantly
recognize the potential for this
information to be weaponized on
a huge scale.
And Pelphrey knew the power she
held.
Her defiant stance, publicly
stated over and over, became her
rallying cry.
If I'm going down, they're all
going down with me.
That phrase just captures the
threat, doesn't it?
Not just to her, but to the
powerful figures who used her
service.
It wasn't just her legal fight.
It was about exposing the
hypocrisy at the highest levels
in DC.
She dared to pull back the
curtain.
And that's exactly why her black
book scared the swamp half to
death.
Washington thrives on that image
of moral rectitude, especially
from leaders pushing family
values.
This book, with its undeniable
documented proof of secret
activities, directly threaten
the clean veneer that moralists
like to drape over the city's
oldest habits.
It wasn't just one scandal you
could contain.
No, it was an existential threat
to the whole facade, the
self-image of moral authority.
It stripped away the pretense,
revealing the rot and hypocrisy
underneath.
The fear wasn't just about the
sex, it was about the exposure
of the hypocrisy.
So the Black Book is out there,
its existence known, this
ticking time bomb.
You'd think a client list from
an operation like Tamela Martin
and associates with powerful DC
figures on it would just
completely turn the city upside
down, right?
You would absolutely think that
our source even asked that exact
question.
You'd think a list that big
would flip the city upside down.
And then the blunt, cynical
answer.
But it didn't.
And that's where you see the
chilling mechanics of the swamp
at work.
Our sources say the the swamp
ate the evidence.
Such a vivid metaphor, like the
environment itself, has this
built in way to absorb,
neutralize and very inconvenient
truths.
The media, which initially
dangled a few Nuggets, just
enough juicy details to grab
headlines and spark some
outrage, ultimately turn the
page.
The intense scrutiny, the
initial anger was carefully
managed and it just faded.
The news cycle moved on, maybe
with a little help.
And the final outcome, the
summary, just drives it home.
A sacrificial lamb or 2A sealed
record Back to business.
Chilling.
It confirms that despite the
huge potential for disruption,
for a real reckoning, the system
did its triage ruthlessly.
A few people were exposed, a few
careers ended publicly, but the
overall structure, the swamp
itself, remained untouched, its
roots maybe even deeper.
And the source states it.
Clearly nobody truly powerful
took the big fall.
That one sentence tells you
everything about where the real
power lies and how good it is in
protecting itself and its key
players from real
accountability.
And when you look at the
specific examples from that
time, this pattern of selective
accountability gets even
clearer, almost painfully
obvious.
Like Randall Tobias.
Right.
Prominent guy in the Bush
administration.
The aids are.
And the irony, as the source
says, it wrote itself.
The guy who pushed abstinence
only policy was found dialing
escorts from his government
phone.
His downfall was immediate,
swift, decisive, gone.
Overnight he became one of those
classic sacrificial lambs, high
profile enough that his removal
looked like action was taken,
but it shut down wider
questions.
And then the complete contrast.
Senator David Vitter, Mr. Family
values from Louisiana, staunch
conservative, always campaigning
on moral purity.
He also got outed for using
palfrey service.
But remarkably, almost
inexplicably, if you're just
watching from the outside, he
was then re elected.
How does that happen?
Well the source gives a reason
bluntly because when you're God
fearing in red enough the base
forgives anything so long as you
keep the receipts sealed.
He's framed as the hypocrite who
survived almost a legend in DC
and maybe more tellingly, the
patron St. of if you stay loyal,
the machine forgives you.
His case shows a different but
equally powerful side of the
swamps self protection.
Not just burying evidence, but
strategically forgiving those
who are useful as long as they
stay loyal.
So Tobias and Vitter, together,
they perfectly illustrate this
nuanced, selective
accountability. 1 falls hard,
career gone.
The other, despite the same kind
of exposure.
Weathers it rebounds, keeps his
power.
Yeah, it really suggests
survival isn't just about what
you did, but about this complex
calculation, your political
usefulness, your base's loyalty,
and, critically, the machine's
ability and willingness to
protect its own, especially the
loyal ones.
It's a stark lesson in how
scandal really plays out in DC,
far from public expectations of
fairness.
OK, this brings us to a core
metaphor our sources use, one
that really ties these stories
together, showing them as part
of a bigger, unsettling pattern.
The cicada brood.
The DC Madam story isn't just
some historical footnote, just a
prequel to Epstein.
It's presented as proof that
every so often the swarm rises
from the mulch.
And what's striking, almost
scary in its consistency, is
it's always the same shape, same
smell, same hush.
It's this recurring pattern,
this predictable cycle of
revelation and containment,
that's the key theme here.
It suggests something
fundamental and unchanging about
how Washington works.
It's a powerful analogy, isn't
it?
Cicadas emerging after years
underground, only to go back.
It really underscores the idea
that despite all the marble and
myths, the grand speeches,
Washington fundamentally runs on
back room deals, closed doors
and names that never appear on
the record.
Exactly.
Those hidden deals, secret
agreements, they aren't
exceptions.
They're the bedrock, the
invisible scaffolding of
influence.
So just like those cicadas
popping up predictably once
every decade or two, it's
chillingly consistent.
Some black book or flight log
bubbles to the surface.
It's this almost inevitable
eruption of secrets, a temporary
breach in the facade.
And the predictable outcome,
which we saw with Palfrey's
limited fallout, is just eerily,
depressingly consistent.
It's like a script that plays
out over and over.
Yeah, the narrative as the
sources lay it out is almost pre
written.
People gasp, names leak, a few
petty heads roll.
There's that momentary shock,
the public outrage, the feeling
that this time it'll be
different.
Real change is coming.
But then, almost always with
this chilling efficiency, the
machine eats the evidence and
moves on the system.
The swamp just shows this
incredible, almost pathological
ability to absorb the shock,
neutralize the threat, and keep
functioning, seemingly unfazed.
It's deeply cynical, but,
according to our sources,
alarmingly accurate.
And this is where Palfrey
becomes more than just another
DC scandal.
She didn't just reveal names.
She was the one who cracked the
facade with nothing more than a
battered notebook and the
courage to say, if I go down, I
take you all with me.
Her importance isn't just who
she exposed, but the deeper
truth she revealed about the
system itself.
She didn't just show names.
She inadvertently, maybe
intentionally, revealed the
formula for how these scandals
are managed, contained and
neutralized.
She showed us the playbook.
And our source breaks down this
formula into 3 chillingly
precise points.
First, the press will get a
taste, but never the feast,
meaning information is carefully
controlled.
Just enough leaks out to satisfy
the public's immediate hunger,
create headlines, maybe quell
some outrage, but never the full
story, Never enough to really
dismantle the system or expose
its roots.
Think how often we get hints,
but never the full unredacted
picture.
OK, second point which we saw at
Tobias.
A few scapegoats will hang, but
never the real architects.
Right.
The systemic triage.
Someone takes the fall off in
someone high profile to appease
the public demand for
accountability.
But the masterminds, the truly
powerful figures pulling
strings, the architects of the
system, enabling it all, they
stay hidden, shielded.
It's a strategic sacrifice to
protect the larger structure.
And the third part of the
formula?
Maybe the most cynical The
moralists who run your town are
the filthiest ones in the room.
This cuts right to the heart of
DC's power structure.
It suggests those who preach
morality loudest, who build
careers on virtue and family
values, are often the ones most
deeply involved in the very
things they condemn.
It reinforces that idea of
morality as a weapon, a tool for
control, not a genuine
principle.
It's a devastating indictment of
the hypocrisy that lets the
swamp operate.
So when you read about this
stuff, when you can almost smell
the swamp, guess in these pages,
as the source says, you're meant
to remember.
Epstein may be the punchline
now, but Pelphrey was the
warning shot.
She wasn't just a forgotten
scandal.
She was the precursor, the
blueprint, the grim prophecy for
a pattern that would come back
even darker.
The warning is clear.
Every cicada cycle the brood
returns, and every time the
swamp keeps humming right along.
It's the cycle of revelation,
then cynical re entrenchment.
The system adapts, but never
fundamentally changes.
OK, this next part is it's
really chilling.
It connects Palfrey's story to
the bigger picture in a way that
feels almost like foreshadowing.
Our sources highlight Deborah
Jean Palfrey's repeated, very
public statements about not
wanting to harm herself.
She swore she'd never kill
herself, said it on the radio
and interviews to her lawyers.
The message was crystal clear,
meant to be heard.
I will not do it.
This wasn't vague.
It was a firm, repeated
declaration, almost a plea to be
believed, trying to counter any
future story.
And then, despite those strong
public denials, just weeks after
her conviction, the tragic
reality found hanging in her
mother's shed in Florida.
The official ruling after a
brief investigation.
Suicide by hanging.
On the surface, a clear, if
tragic and convenient end to her
story.
Case closed.
But our source goes a much, much
deeper than the official story.
It brings up this profound,
unofficial link between her
death and a phrase, a meme,
really, that would explode into
popular culture a decade later.
Unofficially, the source says,
she was the template for a meme
that metastasized A decade
later.
Epstein didn't kill himself.
Wow, quite a statement.
It's not presented as just a
coincidence.
It's this unsettling assertion
that her death somehow laid the
groundwork for the pervasive
public distrust that erupted
years later with Epstein.
And the language the source uses
is incredibly blunt.
Stark.
She was the dry run for that
line.
The test case.
Yeah, that's not a vague theory.
It suggests A deeply unsettling
pattern, almost a playbook.
It implies that the convenient
death of someone holding
compromising information sets a
precedent for how these
situations are seen by the
public.
Makes if you ask, was her death
seen as a successful way to
silence inconvenient truths?
So successful it became cultural
shorthand for suspicion when
powerful people die
mysteriously.
It forces you to consider why
that Epstein meme gained such
traction so quickly.
Was it just organic, or did
Palfrey's case provide this
chewing precedent for public
skepticism?
It's a disturbing thought.
And this leads us right into the
Eckstein Echo.
While Palfrey's operation, as we
established, dealt with
consenting adults within a
specific illicit framework, the
shift to Jeffrey Epstein's world
is wow, it's a horrific
escalation.
Absolutely horrific.
Exponentially so.
Our source makes the distinction
starkly.
Epstein traded high class call
girls for underage girls, flight
logs and compromise safes.
The very nature of the crime
change fundamentally, moving
from adult vice to the
exploitation of children.
And the scale expanded to
Pelphrey was mostly DC focused,
serving that local political and
business elite.
Epstein's operations spanned
Palm Beach, Manhattan, Little
Saint James.
Yeah, a much broader global
footprint suggesting a bigger
network, deeper international
connections, a more diverse and
powerful clientele.
And just like Pelphrey, he was
meticulous, almost obsessive
with records.
He kept names to the little
black book, the flight logs, the
sealed position tapes.
But these weren't just ledgers,
they were tools of leverage,
control, potential blackmail,
amplified hugely by the criminal
nature of his activities.
The compromise, the compromising
material, wasn't just about
money.
It was about power and control
over influential people.
Our sources stress Epstein was
so much darker and so much
bigger.
Not just the number of victims,
but the complexity of his
operation.
His ring apparently ran on kids,
on leverage, on international
spook rumor mill gossip.
That points to a far more
complex, dangerous web, right?
Orchestrated blackmail, maybe
even intelligence connections.
It elevates the scale way beyond
palfrey.
It's systematic exploitation
designed to gain and maintain
power over a huge network.
And yet, despite the massive
differences in what they were
doing, the shift from adult
encounters to Child
Exploitation, the same script
played out with shocking
precision.
The pattern from Palfoy's black
book recurred with Epstein.
We saw names teased, a few
leaks, no full reveal, just like
before.
Tantalizing glimpses, agonizing
whispers of who was involved,
but the full picture,
frustratingly hidden, never
really came to light.
The system again showed its
mastery of information control.
And then the ultimate, most
disturbing echo, cementing that
test case idea, we talked about
Epstein found dead in a cell, no
camera saw, guards asleep, tapes
gone chilling.
That sequence directly mirrors
the skepticism around Palfrey's
death.
The circumstances of Epstein's
death immediately raised huge
questions, fueled massive public
distrust, and launched that
meme.
The official story met with
instant, persistent skepticism.
And the contrast in the impact
of the two scandals is really
telling about how the swamp
evolved its defenses, the source
notes. 1 Black Book cracked the
capital.
Palfrey's records caused real
fear, some real fallout, right?
Limited but real.
But Epstein's trove, his book
logs, tapes arguably far more
damaging, implicating global
figures.
Another never even got opened.
It highlights the enduring,
maybe even more refined, power
of the swamp to protect itself,
suppress information, avoid a
real reckoning even facing what
should have been an
unprecedented crisis.
It suggests the mechanisms of
control got even more
sophisticated between the two
events.
The system learned get adapted
okay.
In this really intricate, high
stakes game of secrets and
power, there are always key
players, right?
A cast of characters popping up
in this swamp story, as our
sources call it.
Definitely.
First Deborah Jean Palfrey,
herself the OG Madam.
The source describes her not as
some shadowy blackmailer agent,
but just a stubborn woman who
thought her list made her
bulletproof.
And, tragically, she was wrong.
Her story is kind of a lesson in
the naive hope that simple truth
can be entrenched power.
Then Randall Tobias presented as
the abstinence crusader, public
persona built on morality,
private actions totally
opposite.
He's the first dominor to fall
after Paul Fries list surfaced.
A classic example of the system
sacrificing 1 high profile
person to contain the damage.
His quick exit looked like
accountability but didn't shake
the foundations.
And contrast him sharply with
David Vitter, Mr. Family values
from Louisiana.
He's the hypocrite who survived
a rare telling exception and
more pointedly still, the patron
St. of If you stay loyal, the
machine forgives you.
Right.
His survival highlights that
selective, politically
calculated accountability.
Loyalty, it seems, often Trump's
morality in the swamp.
Jeffrey Epstein is chillingly
called the Evolution.
He represents that dark
progression from Palfrey's
world.
Kids instead of consenting
adults, private islands instead
of town cars, kompromat instead
of hotel receipts.
He's the amplified, global
version of these patterns,
embodying a much more disturbing
international network of
exploitation and leverage.
His key enabler, Ghislaine
Maxwell, is identified as the
facilitator, the fixer, the
Madam.
For a darker age, she reportedly
made his operations possible,
the orchestrator, the shadowy
infrastructure behind it all?
A crucial figure.
We also see figures like Pam
Bondi described as the I have
the files.
Oh wait, maybe I don't talking
head.
This seems to highlight the
performative aspect, right?
Officials promising big
revelations that often fizzle
out.
Files disappear or less
significant than claimed.
A deflection tactic.
And then people like Cash, Patel
and Bongino presented as the
insider saying there's no list,
which interestingly doesn't stop
the suspicion.
It only makes people want it
more.
Their denials seem to fuel the
public's distrust and hunger for
the hidden truth.
It's like reverse psychology.
Finally, Elon Musk gets a
mention as the jilted mega donor
swears he'll burn the swamp that
just keeps burning him.
This points to a wider
frustration, even among powerful
outsiders, with how impenetrable
and self protective the DC
system is.
Yeah, each of these characters,
in your own way, illustrate some
facet of this complex game
played when dark secrets
surface.
It shows how different people
navigate or fail to navigate the
swamps treacherous waters.
Now, when we talk about these
deep, hidden currents in
Washington, the line between
rumor and reality gets really
blurry, doesn't it?
The amount of speculation around
these figures, these scandals,
is just huge.
Oh, absolutely.
And our sources tackle some of
the most persistent whispers,
then offer these blunt reality
checks, kind of leaving you to
connect the dots yourself.
Right, like with Palfrey, the
rumor that she had Pentagon
generals and agency guys as
clients, top military and
intelligence people.
The sources Reality.
Ambiguous.
Probably true.
Most never confirmed.
All conveniently sealed.
It's not a denial.
It acknowledges it's likely, but
then cynically points to the
system burying sensitive info,
making it impossible to confirm.
And the other big palfrey rumor?
She was silenced to save the
Bush admin.
The reality offered is less
definitive, but just as
suggestive.
She was an inconvenient loose
end.
You decide.
Yeah, that you decide.
It doesn't give an answer, but
it leaves the door wide open.
It implies maybe there's no
direct proof, but the motive,
the political convenience, was
certainly there.
That forces you to think about
the circumstances.
Moving to Epstein, the huge
rumor Epstein was a Mossad or
CIA asset fueled by the sheer
power of his network.
The sources?
Reality check again.
Intriguing.
Nobody's proved it, but that
townhouse was wired for
something.
Again, not confirming, not
denying, but pointing to
circumstantial evidence they
heavily wired property that
fuels the very speculation it's
addressing suggest maybe
something covert was going on
beyond just.
Vice and the pervasive rumor
that the Clintons and Trump knew
the dirt that these powerful,
often opposing figures knew
about Epstein's activities or
secrets.
The sources response, everyone
knew something.
The real question is who had the
tapes?
That's subtly shifts the focus,
doesn't it?
From just knowing to possessing
actionable leverage.
It suggests the real power isn't
just being aware of the dirt,
but controlling the evidence,
the comproman that could silence
or control others.
Which brings us to the question
that always comes up, the one
the public keeps asking.
Q.
Is there really no list?
And the answer from the source
is so insightful and deeply
cynical.
A.
There's always a list, you're
just not on the team that gets
to see it.
Wow.
So it's not about information
not existing, it's about access
and control.
Deliberately withholding details
from the public reinforces that
theme of information as a weapon
reserved for insiders.
The swamp stays impenetrable to
outsiders.
And the question we all ask,
maybe with hope, maybe with
weariness when these scandals
break.
Q Why do people keep hoping this
time will be different?
The answer is kind of poignant.
A Because everyone wants to
believe the next scandal will be
the final swamp fire.
We crave that catharsis, right?
That final cleansing, that one
event that exposes and
eradicates the corruption, it's
a deep human desire for justice.
But the reality, when asked the
follow up Q why does it never
happen?
Is just as stark.
A Because the swamp knows how to
throw you a scapegoat and keep
the machine running.
It's a sophisticated mechanism,
controlled release, diffusing
pressure, managing outrage,
giving the illusion of
accountability without ever
really reforming the underlying
structures.
It's a testament to the system's
resilience, its adaptability.
It gives you just enough to move
on, but never enough to truly
change.
To really get a handle on this
enduring, almost mythical swamp,
it helps to know the lingo
right, the terminology that
defines its secret operations.
Our sources offer this kind of
grim glossary of sleaze.
Yeah, it's revealing.
Take the Black Book itself.
Not just a Ledger defined as the
hand grenade that never goes off
the way you think it will.
It promises this huge explosion,
a total dismantling, but somehow
the actual fallout is always
contained.
It's full power never hits the
system.
Then SD and Y, the Southern
District of New York, described
chillingly as the vault where
federal secrets go to rot.
Implying that certain legal
bodies, instead of bringing
exposure and justice, can
actually become places where
sensitive, politically charged
details get buried, contained,
just fade away, never see the
light of day, cases dismissed,
investigations shelved.
And that term that's become
disturbingly common suicided not
just suicide, defined as
conveniently dead when the
secrets worth more that way.
It speaks directly to that deep
public suspicion that certain
deaths, especially if people
holding compromising info on the
powerful, aren't what they seem,
suggests foul play masked by a
convenient label.
Kompromat is another key term,
the true currency of the swamp.
Not just dirt, but explicitly
the real currency of the swamp.
Dirt that buys loyalty.
Highlighting the compromising
info isn't just for blackmail or
exposure.
More subtly, maybe more
effectively, it's used to secure
allegiance, compel silence,
maintain control.
Creates this network of mutual
vulnerability among the
powerful.
Compliance through shared
secrets.
And finally, flight logs,
described as the ghost story
version of the Black Book.
More names, fewer consequences.
Right, representing A darker,
more elusive record.
A hinting at broader, maybe
international connections.
Yet despite their potential
scope, they seem to yield even
less accountability than
traditional client lists.
They stay more in the realm of
rumor and unproven speculation
now.
Let's think about how much
society, and just the nature of
scandal itself has changed, our
sources note Once Upon a time,
an escort ring made grown men in
the capital sweat bullets.
That was enough to fill
headlines and ruin careers.
That was Palfrey's era.
Yeah, a conventional Vice
scandal and a fair using an
illicit service that caused
major disruption, ended careers,
dominated news.
There was a clear moral line and
crossing it publicly has severe
consequences.
But today, the landscape is
totally different.
Tinder buzzes like neon sugar
babies brag on TikTok.
The idea of discreet, illicit
encounters feels almost quaint
now, in an age of casual hookups
and blurred public, private
lines.
Our source suggests if a
senator's name turned up on an
escort receipt now, nobody would
even blink.
That kind of scandal on its own
just doesn't have the same
power, the same ability to
outrage.
Public tolerance, or maybe just
weariness, has grown.
However, there's a crucial
difference.
What still resonates, what still
stings, what grips the public,
ignites real outrage and points
to that darker underbelly.
Issues like the kids, the
blackmail, the secret safe since
sealed flight logs.
Exactly.
That's where the pattern
manipulation, abuse, systemic
cover up becomes too obvious to
ignore.
That's the dark core that hasn't
been normalized.
The exploitation and leverage
transcend changing social norms.
It cuts deeper than just sexual
indiscretion.
It's the criminal, coercive
exploitation that still demands
attention even when the system
tries to bury it.
Which brings us back full
circle, to that unending cycle
of the cicada brood.
Every cicada brood Burrows up
from the swamp mud every few
decades.
It's presented as natural,
almost inevitable, A recurring
eruption of uncomfortable
truths.
And every single time, without
fail, predictably,
dishearteningly, the moralists
screen.
They'll drain it while the roots
sink deeper.
The promises of reform, of
cleansing the system, are loud
in public, but the underlying
mechanisms of the swamp, the
deep corruption, the hidden
power systems, only get more
entrenched, more resilient,
seemingly immune to real change.
It's a cycle that feeds on
public hope that systematically
crushes it.
So we've walked through the
shadowy corridors of DC, haven't
we?
From Deborah Jean Palfrey's
discreet operation right up to
Jeffrey Epstein terrifying
global network of exploitation
and leverage.
And what we've seen are these
striking parallels, this
recurring, almost rhythmic rhyme
of history when it comes to
power, secrets, and
accountability.
In the Capital, we've explored
how information gets weaponized,
how secrets are guarded with
ruthless efficiency, and how the
swamp just consistently protects
its own, adapting its defenses
with every new threat.
And as you, the listener,
reflect on these patterns, on
this recurring emergence of
deep, uncomfortable truths, only
for them to be kind of absorbed
back into the system, we're
going to leave you with one
final really provocative thought
from our source material,
something to really chew on as
you think about this cycle of
scandal and supposed reform,
about public hope versus
systemic reality.
Yeah.
Think about this.
It's not the scandal that ever
dies.
It's your hope that this time
the list might actually matter.